other breaking news this afternoon two
ccsd bus drivers attacked in two
separate incidents that's right right
now police are still looking for those
responsible victoria saha is tracking
this for us she is near tonopah and
vegas drive by the site of one of those
assaults victoria good afternoon
good afternoon to you both this is still
an ongoing investigation so information
is still very limited but here's what we
know right now
one of the drivers was attacked this
morning right here on tonopah that's
near vegas and washington the school
district releasing the news on thursday
as they investigate two attacks on bus
drivers the first driver was attacked
wednesday evening during an after school
route near boulder and russell that
incident involved multiple attackers
then during a morning route today
another driver targeted this incident
involved one assailant i'm told the
attackers in both incidents were adults
but not students who were 18 but they do
know who they are they have just not
been able to release them yet and just a
few weeks ago the school district
announced a six million dollar project
to add nine new security cameras on each
bus but we're still working to find out
if those attacks happened on either of
those buses victoria zaha 8 news now
thank you victoria superintendent dr
jesus jarrow releasing a statement about
this it reads in part quote i condemn
the violent attack on our bus drivers in
the strongest terms as i have said
repeatedly the clark county school
district will not tolerate attacks on
our staff or students by anyone
once this investigation concludes these
cases will be prosecuted to the fullest
extent of the law